abandonne le patron bien Nathan [ __ ] es-tu
toujours en boîte de nuit maintenant ouais bien sûr
ouais tu sembles être en pleine forme
non c'est ma propre idée
euh-huh non c'est un il arrive un moment et
tu sais que c'est normal de grandir quoi que ce soit de
mal l'a mal frappé est-il vrai que quand tu l'as
rencontrée elle était à un concert au Japon et
tu l'as vue au premier rang  et tu as
demandé à Rudy d'aller lui demander de venir
avec toi ouais c'est vrai pourquoi
as-tu fait ça quelque chose dans tes yeux tu
sais j'aime j'aime regarder les gens
quand je travaille de toute façon et quelque chose quelque
chose qui vit là-dedans ouais un
personnage toi  sais que tu en as marre de
filles différentes chaque nuit tu
demandes 40 dollars pour le taxi et
te
laisses des maladies  alors maintenant
tu es comme John Lennon le ferait  tu vis
à New York avec la fille japonaise et
tu es assez euh euh Dieu tu es très
hétéro non euh je suis assez hétéro je
ne suis pas comme je ne suis pas un ou je n'ai pas de
règle comme  Je ne sais jamais que
c'est du vin ouais non ce n'est pas pour être
riche là-bas tu paies bien
je joue mon père oui il y a quelque chose tu
sais que nous sommes tous les deux des hommes et et il est beaucoup
plus âgé que moi et donc quand nous nous
réunissons nous ne '  Je ne veux pas vraiment
discuter, tu sais qu'ils vont bonjour, ravis de te voir,
alors nous jouons au golf pour quelque chose à faire
ensemble, est-il vrai que ton père, comme
toujours, s'identifie aux chansons quand tu joues bien avec
lui et que tu dis oui, j'ai un  ID et
tu dis non papa non non ouais il
essaie constamment de me vendre son
idée de chanson ouais ouais et tu places une fille avec
ton fils Eric non non uh-huh
mais je vois beaucoup Eric quand je vais à
Hollywood c'est un gamin d'Hollywood il  chante en
sauvegarde sur l'une des chansons de mes nouveaux
disques qu'il chante sur l'invaincu oh
ouais tu es de brick by break
ouais avec environ 15 autres gars ouais c'est
comme un bu  nch de gars que vous dites à propos de votre
nouvel album c'est la chose la plus articulée
que j'ai faite depuis l'idée en 77 ouais
ouais quand j'ai fait quand j'ai fait l'idiot
David Bowie a composé toute la musique la plupart
de la musique pour ça
et je travaillais très dur  juste pour me
concentrer sur les paroles et cette
fois j'ai mis autant de travail dans les paroles
et j'ai aussi écrit la musique ouais ça a juste
travaillé plus fort en
gros ouais tu sais simple c'est que
vraiment tu as deux gars de gun et
le thon de Rosie uh-huh ouais et  tu chantes un
duo avec l'étrange avec Kate Pierson
de 52 ouais bien sûr les garçons volent
comme un avion comme un b-52 je suppose que je
pense que des choses sortent d'eux tu joues de la guitare
oh oui la toute première fois j'ai
toujours écrit dessus avant  mais mes styles sont
très bruts et j'ai toujours embauché
des gens plus professionnels et celui-ci, je me suis en quelque
sorte amusé à jouer avec chaque
guitariste différent invité et j'ai senti que c'était
plus réel parce que souvent le chanteur
du groupe est souvent dans une
position frustrée ouais parce qu'il  h  comme
tu n'as pas l'instrument tu sais et il n'a aucun
contrôle tu sais ce qui se passe
donc parfois c'est vraiment sympa de le
prendre et ça vient de toi au
début toi notre batteur ouais
et puis quand tu as vu Jim Morrison ou
Mick Jagger tu  j'ai décidé d'être chanteur
eh bien je voulais être chanteur ouais mais
c'est quand j'ai vu ces gars que j'étais
plus poussé c'était comme si je ne pouvais plus attendre
c'est ridicule tu sais quand
tu étais enfant tu vivais à
Ypsilanti  près de hannahb ou près de Detroit
ouais et tes parents nous vivons dans un
camp de roulottes oui et c'est vrai que
tu joues de la batterie dans la roulotte c'est
vrai ouais mais nous sommes dans la roulotte
eh bien il y avait une grande chambre une
chambre principale  pour eux
farik assez grand pour puis une chambre plus petite
pour moi quand j'ai eu ma batterie ils
ont abandonné leur chambre ouais oui et ils
ont sorti toutes leurs affaires de leur chambre
et m'ont donné cette chambre pourquoi tu ne jouerais pas
pour me permettre  pour jouer, ce sont
des gens très très merveilleux et le  J'ai dormi dans
une très très petite chambre et ils ont fait ça
pendant trois ans tout au long du lycée
et quand je jouais si
tout tremblait et que ça faisait un gros bruit mais
ils étaient toujours très bons à ce sujet
J'ai vraiment de la chance à ce moment-là
vous soutenez les Yankees de New York oui
oui je ne peux pas y croire j'ai vraiment aimé
ils étaient une équipe de classe vous savez
ils avaient tout ce qu'ils avaient du pouvoir ils
avaient de la vitesse ils avaient euh ils avaient du cerveau
mais la plupart ils avaient une grande personnalité
cette équipe qu'ils avaient et vous avez même rejoint
les bottes de brousse à cette époque c'est vrai
j'étais un scout louveteau mais j'ai été expulsé
des coupes pour avoir fait ça avec un
élastique vous savez lors des réunions est-
il vrai qu'un jour votre  père et
mère nous écoutons Sinatra à la
radio
et ton père dit que les gens du show business
sont l'aristocratie de ce Calgary tu
sais montrer que les artistes sont un nouvel
héritier aristocrate de ce pays et j'ai
écouté et tout ce que j'ai décidé d'être une
star eh bien j'étais  b déchiré  entre je voulais
vraiment être un politicien et ça m'intéressait vraiment mais quand j'ai commencé à
jouer, c'était beaucoup plus amusant de jouer
et de s'asseoir autour de parler et aussi kennedy a
été abattu et quand il a été abattu, je pense que
beaucoup de gens dans  L'Amérique est devenue plus
cynique ouais c'est un peu comme hé attendez
une minute quelque chose ne va pas vous savez donc ça
m'a un peu rebuté et votre premier livre
vaut peut-être des iguanes et c'est pourquoi
votre nom était votre vrai nom n'est pas Iggy
Pop Jim une fraise ouais  et puis
tu as décidé de te ressaisir
j'avais un NIC c'était un surnom ouais d'autres
personnes m'appellent comme ça et puis bien j'ai juste
abandonné ouais d'accord et maintenant j'aime ça
tu sais et comment as-tu rencontré le
frère Ashton Rama dans un groupe local  et c'est un
bon bassiste vraiment bon et son
frère j'étais un batteur j'étais en quelque sorte l'
un des meilleurs batteurs de la ville et
frère c'était ça juste
traîner et me regarder jouer du tambour et finalement un
jour dit tu sais que j'aimerais  pour apprendre le
drame et tu enseignes  moi et tu as commencé
ça - jeez ouais tu es influencé par
les Kings font les étudiants la porte il
a beaucoup plus de dysphorie et aussi par aussi
par toute la musique qui sortait
du genre du croissant du Moyen-Orient j'ai
remarqué que certains des  des groupes j'aime bien
on utilise du dim
blues et je me disais bien que les sources se
tarissaient allons plus loin de chez nous et
tu étais influencé par le traditionnel
extrêmement argent extrêmement par Coltrane euh
moi toujours et aussi Shep et Albert Ayler
ouais et vraiment ces trois là étaient comme
les  Trinity et moi avons toujours
senti que j'essayais toujours d'utiliser mon corps de
la même manière qu'ils utiliseraient leur
saxophone de manière lyrique dans ma
prestation de chant, c'était plus vous savez Jagger
Dylan Lou Reed vous savez essayer d'
imiter ces gars qui étaient mes héros  donc
tu as eu les premiers gens en 67 tu es
un très bon père je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
mais des années plus tard quand la six bête
ou un nouveau plaisir tu n'avais plus de groupe
que Dino où tu étais triste d'être seul à
cette fois et ferb pas de place je ne pouvais pas je ne me suis
jamais assis et j'ai pensé que j'aimerais que
nous soyons ensemble quelque chose comme ça je suis
trop réaliste il y avait une raison pour
laquelle ça s'est terminé et quand ça s'est terminé ça s'est terminé
ouais c'est solitaire parfois le plus heureux un
solo oui solitaire un autre groupe
étant un groupe a beaucoup de
tension deux groupes se séparent les gens
meurent ouais euh beaucoup de fois
quelqu'un d'autre reçoit l'argent vous savez que les
choses arrivent donc vous avez eu le premier
à  portez un jean bleu soigné vous avez eu le
premier il allait déchirer mon
jean bleu ouais mais je ne l'ai pas coupé en premier
comme les autres le font sauté sur vos
genoux j'étais à genoux regarder j'ai commencé à
déchirer et j'ai pensé wow  ça a l'air
plutôt cool tu sais que tu as eu le premier
ami à abuser de toi ou de ton pote avec
des bouteilles en verre - non je ne l'ai fait que deux fois
ouais euh ouais c'était ce n'était pas une
expérience heureuse je l'ai fait parce que j'étais très
très déçu de  ce
moment particulier c'est juste arrivé
j'étais le premier  un à la plongée sur scène - je suis un
peu fier de ce que beaucoup de bonbons
beaucoup de gens s'amusent à faire ça tu
sais tu sais tu sais donc ton premier
album le premier album d'Alice - jeez a été
produit par John Hale et il était vraiment
comme une baby-sitter pour vous parce qu'il
vous a laissé faire ce que vous vouliez faire maintenant si
nous essayions de faire ce que nous faisions sans
personne pour le justifier auprès de l'entreprise, nous
aurions eu un gâchis mais ils ils pour
une raison quelconque ils lui faisaient confiance je  pas
là je sais pas pourquoi c'est vrai
qu'il faisait les séances
il était habillé comme un dragon ouais ouais
il s'habillait comme bien pas totalement Dracula
mais il portait dans ma mémoire il portait une grande
longue cape noire avec un  grande chose comme
ça et il avait l'air très cool et
Nico venait aux séances de temps en
temps ouais
ouais tu avais l'amant de Nico à ce
moment-là, elle t'a dit du sexe j'ai entendu n'importe quoi
et elle ne frapperait pas ouais tu sais qu'elle
ne le ferait pas  frappé pendant que nous jouions cette
musique très forte, votre deuxième album a été
envoyé, puis w  avec un groupe toi tu es
descendu dans l'héroïne de cocaïne aux champignons
et c'était mauvais pour toi quelle est la pire
chose que tu fasses à ce moment-là pour trouver la
pluie d'été une fois que j'en avais marqué j'étais dans une
voiture de location qui ne l'avait pas payé  et
je ne pouvais pas le prendre là où je l'avais marqué et
j'avais tellement hâte de le prendre que je suis allé je me
suis arrêté dans une station-service où et je suis
allé dans les toilettes des hommes et il y avait
un cendrier vous devez avoir quelque chose pour le
cuisiner  le cendrier était très sale et
donc beaucoup de saleté y est entré et j'ai eu une
très mauvaise réaction
ce n'est pas très c'est très douloureux parler
de ce client ouais alors nous avons rencontré Tony
DeFries parce que Bowie était déjà
intéressé par toi je sais que tu t'as amené
au  Bureau de bus CVS et est-il vrai
que la première fois que vous vous êtes approché de la
chanson de Sanger Sinatra sur Anthony, demandez honnêtement à une
fille les fans juste et chantez même partagez le sourire
un peu de ma drôle de Valentine ouais
et puis ça a mal tourné parce que tu
ne voulais pas  devenir une star quand tu as
vu David Bowie à ce di  e tu ne
voulais pas devenir comme lui
non c'est une déclaration assez juste je le
respectais et mais j'avais quelque chose en
moi que je voulais vraiment
vraiment faire et je savais en quelque sorte à l'avance
qu'ils avaient d'autres plans pour moi  c'était
difficile d'émettre Robbo parce que tu es
allé à Los Angeles, il est de toute façon à l'
hôpital et tu es juste autorisé à
sortir pour chanter sous rappel et ensuite tu es
revenu dans le tien non c'était sur un
disque plus tard donc nous avons passé un très mauvais moment
le  la seule chose que nous avons réussi à enregistrer était
un album intitulé kill City et
c'était celui où j'ai fait le chant le week-
end parce que j'étais dans un hôpital ouais, c'est-à-dire
que je l'ai fait pour mon propre
bien parce que j'ai réalisé que tu n'avais pas
réussi  pour te gérer plus ce
signal de prendre soin de moi je ouais c'est
vrai je ne savais plus comment j'avais perdu
la capacité ouais ouais alors comme beaucoup de
gens ouais en 1976 tu es allé à Berlin
avec un David Bowie pour finir le  idiot
oui tu avais commencé dans un rubis ouais bien
ouais  et vous avez passé du bon temps là-bas et bien
là, il se balance il y avait une
grande, vous savez, c'est une grande grande ville
physiquement c'est énorme ouais et elle a été
construite pour que beaucoup plus de gens vivent
là-bas il y avait
alors c'était vraiment vide et les gens
qui étaient là, ils étaient très
gris à la limite de la vie et beaucoup de
réfractaires fuyaient
l'armée beaucoup d'étudiants et des restes d'
artistes étranges comme l'expédition était
intégré dans une boîte de nuit sais que j'ai écrit que
j'avais écrit ça avant d'y arriver  était à
peu près en gros j'ai été en tournée
avec David et je sortais juste
tous les soirs avec lui sortir tous les
soirs tous les soirs disco disco juste tous les
night club club club et donc c'était l'
idée de ça ce n'était pas censé  être sur
ce disque c'était le disque était presque
terminé et lui et moi et un de ses amis
étions juste en train de gaffer dans le
studio et il a mis l'un de ces
masques en caoutchouc d'un très vieux mon vieil homme d'un vieil
homme et courant  autour et il se mit au
piano et a commencé à jouer une sorte de musique de vieil
homme comme Hoagy Carmichael ouais et
il joue cette musique j'ai retourné et j'ai
dit que c'était génial parce que j'ai toujours
eu la capacité de reconnaître la
musique et d'autres personnes c'est vous savez
c'est un peu quoi  Je suis bon et
je suis juste allé whoa c'est génial s'il
vous plaît comme je peux faire une parole cela peut être
génial vous savez je ne suis pas si bon mais je l'ai
convaincu et donc nous l'avons fait et
puis il a bien pensé le tambour  le talent de la boîte à
rythmes sonne trop bon marché parce
que c'était comme une boîte à rythmes à 98 $ J'ai vraiment
aimé la coupe que nous avons prise et tu as dit à propos de
valine que le monde protégeait la ville
de tous les connards du monde c'est ce
que je ressentais ouais surtout parce que nous
avions été toi  Je sais que lui et
moi vivions à Los Angeles, il était un peu
plus au-dessus, j'étais au-
dessous, mais à Berlin, c'était
la première ville où je vivais où les gens
ne se penchaient pas et s'embrassaient  le rock and
roll demande pour la mauvaise raison ce qu'a fait
Dav  id Bowie vous a écrit allumez-moi je
n'ai jamais vraiment entendu parler de ballet ouais d'accord
vous m'allumez en jet ski et joggle un
ami toute une histoire du Ballet Russe
toute l'idée toute l'idée d'artistes
de différentes disciplines travaillant
ensemble et il  toute l'idée que personne
ne m'a jamais dit hé tu sais que tu pourrais
être peintre ouais parce que je fais ces
petits dessins et tu devrais peindre alors
il m'a montré comment préparer une toile
parce qu'il avait été à l'école d'art tu sais
me montrer à chaque fois  il était là, vous savez,
chaque fois que j'avais des problèmes et il était, vous savez
, c'est une personne très travailleuse
et cela a déteint sur la vie pour être assez
paresseux trop indulgent ouais et je
pensais que Dieu ce gars était dur,
cela pourrait être une bonne leçon et
webdriver qu'as-tu apporté à David
Bowie je ne peux pas dire que je serais pour lui de
dire je ne sais pas mais sans cochon pas de
Ziggy de toute évidence je suppose donc oui
semble avoir une partie de mon nom là
-dedans et un  le jour d'après qu'Elton John
voulait produire  vous et vous savez que vous avez nourri
500 000 $ de maison sous la colline non et j'ai dit
quand je l'ai regardé j'ai vu du vin Oh des
endroits perfides et en fait derrière
eux
cela ne s'intéressait pas à nous à
un moment donné je ne sais pas à quel point il était intéressé
mais il a vraiment  aimait James ouais
Williamson tu sais qu'il avait un faible
pour James et ça n'est jamais allé nulle part
tu sais que tu es une légende j'aime juste
faire une bonne chanson que quelqu'un t'aime bien
tu penses que tu aurais pu être plus grand
sans drogue  façon de
dire, mais je veux dire que je suis plus grand que je ne l'étais
l'année dernière
ouais donc tu sais que je ne vais pas bien